[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening friends
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
hey um obviously the news just literally
broke
i was getting in the shower to come here
and i got a text from mark and he said
we have a story to lead with and there
it was
uh heartbreaking news the great chadwick
boseman
uh t'challa himself
jackie robinson jacob robinson thurgood
marshall thurgood marshall and uh
james brown played a host of roles but
of course
for the purposes and intents of our show
the king of wakanda himself good night
sweet prince farewell to the king
we've lost uh a great actor how many
times did he play
black panther so civil war civil war
black
black panther and then both avengers
movies so four times
i mean a short life at age 43 cut
tragically short by colon cancer
did anybody know this i mean i have to
imagine that his inner circle knew
right you know but this wasn't pub i'm
not crazy it was an incredibly well-kept
secret
you know and i'm sure at his behest he
seemed to be a very private person
for as much as he you know would go out
on the on the circuit and advertise his
movies and talk with fans
the interior life of chadwick boseman
was was a mystery to most
in a way that i think he might have
patterned after classic movie stars of
old
yes you know the like the the more the
mystery the better it is for me to step
into these roles
and so that he can be these totemic
history you know figures in
in both black history the less you know
about him the easier it is to buy him as
whoever he's playing you know but
apparently he was diagnosed the year
black panther came out
2016 um and you know went through
you know rounds of surgeries and
treatments and and and
all kinds of stuff trying to to bat it
aside and
and and win the fight and through it all
kept working yes you know through it all
kept
you know making marvel movies making you
know
the five bloods the last picture that he
that was released that he was that he
shot the
spike lee sort of vietnam war movie
right right um
you know in which he looked thin in
which he looked a little frail
um i remember like not too many months
ago he looked
thin in some photos and people were like
is he going to be
in black panther still is he going to be
ready um
look i mean
who could have guessed from the outside
if you didn't know
no um never in a million years
would i have assumed like oh so young
and battling colon cancer but right and
who looked so vibrant and
incredibly vibrant you know every time
you saw him on screen
there was a physicality to him i mean
you can't not be physical when you're
playing james brown you can't not be
physical playing jackie robinson you
can't not be physical playing
t'challa the king of wakanda and uh and
i mean he's clearly was an actor through
and through because we never saw it
in any of those performances that he was
fighting anything beyond
the the enemies on the screen shooting
star
comet man burned insanely bright
um impacted this business in a big bad
way over the course of like
not even fully a decade yeah i mean near
as i can put together his first movie
was really 2012 2013 i mean 42 was the
one that broke him huge right
and that was 2013. so that's not nine
years ago
i met um like i said on twitter um only
one time
and it was for the stan lee when stan
got his hand feet prints in the cement
at the chinese theater four court
courtesy of the legion m folks and uh i
was an
emcee and then there were speakers and
todd mcfarlane was one of them and
um um agents of shield
clark correct clark was one of them and
um
uh james gunn kevin feige
and chadwick boseman and he was nice
and a nice guy very quiet
um and a little nervous about having to
go up and speak but gave a wonderful
speech
um carried himself as regally as the
character we most he's most well known
for playing
um seemed like a really really good dude
but
you've definitely hit on something with
the
like uh person the old actor persona
he wasn't like i i remember a piece that
he did it's not like he didn't do things
he was on snl and he was
[ __ ] amazing on snl um
any remember he was he was t'challa on
snl where he's doing the
where he's figuring out the potato salad
he was just karen t'challa
black pepper does not season yes her
potato sauce the rise of the karen in
popular culture
is in in great part due to chadwick
boseman on
celebrity black jeopardy he was uh
wonderful there
there was a piece he did on uh
jimmy fallon where you know they had
people
walking up to a poster of black panther
and like
just like hey we're shooting you and
we're going to show this
to chadwick boseman but he was right
behind the thing and so
people would talk and then he'd come out
and they'd be like
um but yeah he disappeared into his
roles and wasn't like
a big figure in public life from what i
saw yeah i mean i i think that he
playing a character like t'challa is a
massive responsibility given
what that character was going to mean to
a generation of both moviegoers um
and lots of generations of
african-americans and
and people of color all over the world
and it's the mantle of that is heavy
to to bear and he seemed to bear it as
lightly as a person could bear
you know there was there was an entire
the black panther vortex
you know spread long and wide from the
january before the movie came out
all the way through oscar season you
know when it won a bunch of oscars and
you know the cast won a bunch of awards
and at the sags and so on and so on and
so
he became you know the the standard
bearer
for that movie and watching him do that
press and watching him walk out there
and lift up everybody around him
and make everybody who came into his
orbit feel better about themselves yeah
and he did it with such grace you know
the kind of grace of a person who
has been in the limelight for a bit but
also who had a life before this
you know and who you know made some
struggles and fought some
some fights and won most of them you
know there's there was a great moment
when
i think he was speaking i want to say
was like denzel washington's afr
lifetime achievement award something or
other
um or or one of the these sort of award
season sag things
and he mentioned to denzel that when he
was a kid um
and he wanted to go to college he was
able to go by the through the good
graces of
you know sort of the the beneficiaries
of people who donated money to the
school and one of them was chadwick and
chadwick doesn't go to college unless
denzel washington bankrolls how
beautiful is that and for him to be able
to be on that stage at that moment and
then tell him that i think that i don't
think denzel knew like he you know
donates money who knows who gets these
freaking grants
it's cosmically beautiful but
something you probably wouldn't notice
when we were in the moment but
he packed a lot of living into a short
span of time at least as far as the
business i can't speak to his personal
life but
as far as the business like he'll you
know
be in he's in movies that people won't
forget forever
yes huge movies in the biggest movie of
all
of all time um three of them
for that matter i would imagine three of
the biggest movies of all time
um and you know
aside from the marvel roles which you
know were
also stand out um having a moment where
you get to
acknowledge the people who went before
you without whom you might not have been
there like
that's no time in retrospect no time was
wasted and maybe that's perhaps because
he
knew yeah he's how long has been going
on four years they said four years he
had diagnosed in 2016
and that gives a person some perspective
yeah you know and allows them to take
the most advantage of the time that they
have
for how however much time you get um
and it's it's did he have was he married
or he was married i'm not sure if he had
children or not you know the the the
statement that goes out to his family
yeah the statement that was released by
his twitter was that well i'll read it
because
i have it um it is with the measurable
grief that we confirm the passing of
chadwick boseman chadwick was diagnosed
with stage three colon cancer in 2016
and battled it
these last four years as it progressed
to stage four a true fighter chadwick
persevered through it all
and though and were
and brought you my glasses right here
and i'm not using them no worries
and and brought you many of the films
you have come to love so much from
marshall to defy bloods
august wilson's ma rainey's black bottom
which he shot before he passed
which one what was it ma rainey's black
bottom so that's one more movie coming
yeah it's an adaptation that august
wilson play and silver more all were
filmed during and between
countless surgeries and and chemotherapy
it was the honor of his career to bring
king t'challa to life in black panther
he died in his home with his wife and
family by his side
the family thanks you for your love and
prayers and ask that you continue to
respect their privacy during this
difficult time
heart goes out to his wife ben because
you know she had to share him
for the last yeah for ever since black
panther she had to share him with the
world
while he's going through this and i'm
sure on some level
there's like you know well at least
there's this at least professionally
things are going well
as personally things are not going well
but
you know you would want to spend every
moment with that person
you know just in case yeah so
generous of her to share them with all
of us
i mean that's the thing about pop
culture is we take people in as our own
very quickly and we watch their work
so often so repeatedly that they become
members of the family um you will think
about how many times you've gone online
and defended a total [ __ ] stranger
that you'll never meet
just because their work moved you
something fierce
he was that and still is for a lot of
people a lot of people
like us were surprised what where did
this come from
there are a lot of people absolutely
devastated like for whom like i loved
black panther but there are people for
whom black panther is
like as emotionally powerful for them as
seeing batman in 1989
tim burton was for me and add way more
you know credibility and and
socio-political importance
to seeing black panther for the first
time so
think about the you know not only is it
a loss to the people who knew him
personally
but people who are just fans like you
said people who are like
there's a lot of you know import placed
on that role
for not just what it was historically
within comics and pop culture
but what it became it was one of the
highest grossing films of all time
yeah and showed the world that like all
your conventional wisdom about what type
of movies work at the box office
has been upended you know and there's
there's a generation of kids for whom he
was their superhero
yes and for him adam west or something
like that
and for them this is their first real
brush with this kind of feeling of
it's the first poster i had on my wall
it's the first movie that i ever
saved in my allowance to buy it's the
first celebrity death
for them in a in both an abstract way in
a very
close way and if you're feeling
isolated or i know in a moment like like
2020 has been an absolute [ __ ] nut
biter
and it sometimes it takes very little to
push people over the edge and whatnot so
if you're feeling alone if you're
feeling frustrated if you're feeling
like [ __ ] this world right now
reach out to some friends hang out with
us for a little while
it's crazy what the death of someone you
barely knew
could bring up in your own life
because of the role that pop culture
plays in our
daily lives man it was shocking when i
saw that
the the text that you sent because i was
like i what
did anybody say anything how is this
possible yeah i mean i
i i really enjoyed him as an actor i
never knew him as a person
um but you know
when you are young and you in like
when kurt cobain passes away yeah you
know when
when somebody that's john belushi when
we were kids yeah you know i mean [ __ ]
when prince passed away and we were
we were old ass adults you know the the
before their time person who meant
something to you
even in the abstract and sometimes in
the very specific you know it can throw
you for a loop and it can
knock you off your balance so yes like
kev said if you're feeling adrift and
you need to talk reach out
friends family there are hotlines
there's any number of ways for you to
get resources
and to take care of your own mental
health and
you know take care of your own health
period it's not as if
you know he didn't do anything wrong no
you know it's not like that's the thing
it's like like anybody who gets sick
like
well i mean you know in my case i had a
[ __ ] heart attack because i ate wrong
and [ __ ]
blah blah something like that colon
cancer is not a cancer that's brought
about
by activity or lifestyle it's in your
dna it's
in you know it's it's luck of the draw
kind of thing or
bad luck of the draw um
yeah man it's 43
way too [ __ ] young and he obviously
gave so much
and had so much more to give like i you
take for granted
where you're like i'll be watching him
play [ __ ] t'challa for years at least
two more movies that movie was so huge
there's no way they don't and then
life throws your curveball through him a
pretty vicious one
um that's just heartbreaking man
it's such a bummer what a [ __ ] bad
year yeah
i would like a do-over please to say the
least
um man oh man what uh
yeah i mean the only thing that he had
you know he was still working
you know kind of up until the end i'm
not entirely sure when
when ma rainey's black bottom which is a
sort of 1920s kind of blues jazz
thing um when it was shot or when it was
scheduled to come out the only
information was like 2020 was the
release date but who knows what that
means
you know nothing had been shot on black
panther two
i'm pretty sure they're still in the
script phase
so who who knows what the plan going
forward for any of those things are
and i'm sure it's the least on anybody's
minds um
who knew him and knew him well when
or what to do about that you know i
think people are still just grieving and
reeling
at the news but yeah it's
it's it is a devastating loss not just
for what he did
but what he could have done and what
more we could have seen
if you're just tuning in uh chadwick
boseman
black panther himself king t'challa uh
passed away and we're uh eulogizing
yes a wonderful actor who over a short
period of time
impacted pop culture you know like the
like a meteor strike in the earth that
later
then helps develop into vibranium
just to keep it in our world just to
keep it on point um
man oh man what uh
what is the what are people saying right
now jc
in the chat room got anybody in need
a lot of people who are a lot of people
are
very very sad and upset
um and kind of a lot of people saying
like uh black mamba
and black panther are both gone a lot of
[ __ ] 2020s
yeah yeah and apparently he died on
jackie robinson's birthday
and jack kirby's birthday today is jack
kirby's birthday
man alive is that chat and
jack kirby drew black panther created
the character with
stan um i'm sure somebody will put
together some crazy conspiracy
lincoln kennedy kind of thing yeah um
what a bummer man my heart goes out to
everyone out there like us just fans on
the sidelines going no
but our hearts really go out to his
family and friends
ryan coogler must be yeah anybody who
knew him anybody got to work with him
anybody who was touched by him because
he was
he was you know both a visible person
and out there in the world but also a
private person who kept things very
close to the vest
but touched a lot of lives you know in
ways both big and small
so yeah our heart goes out rest in peace
i'm sure we'll be talking about them
throughout the rest of the evening um
we were not prepared for this to say the
least but you know
we're not we're not the ones who had to
be prepared
um damn have you ever set
vigil death watch for a family member
i've i've
i've never had to do that i mean i've
i've had
you know my both of my grandparents died
of natural causes and
late in life you know 96 and 97 they
both lived until
i mean heavens wow yeah no there's
there's some lungs you've got some good
dna kid
not so bad so so you know i've visited
people
sort of on their you know on making
their final bows
but i've never nobody was ever sick
nobody was ever
suffering i've had three
four grandparents like slowly
die two of them like while i was a kid
and like right around the block from me
and stuff so like
it's you want to talk about a feeling of
helplessness and hopelessness
you can't do anything at a certain point
you make a person comfortable try to
make them feel good but even then
it gets to a place where nothing can be
done
so hopefully it wasn't a painful was not
a painful end for
for him um but how could it
not be you never hear of anybody talking
about like
colon cancer and it was like oh it
wasn't bad yeah it's always awful
um this is going to be a little bit
awkward about face but
we have a sponsor tonight we get to do a
show like this because
somebody is uh is footing the bills for
us man so we figured we would lead off
the show
with a little chadwick boseman memorial
and then sort of
start the show over again and you get to
watch us reset
because otherwise the whiplash would
have been a bit severe yeah especially
given our sponsor
and it's a good sponsor it's a very good
sponsor i have used some of their
products the [ __ ]
not in the way that they would have you
used them
i mean that now i'm curious hold on
yeah i know what we're about to talk
about but i'm like what do you mean
um the good folks at manscaped
ladies and gentlemen manscaped.com are
sponsoring our show this evening
these are the folks that care about your
ball hair
yeah no nobody in this life has ever
cared about that until now
no other than like complaints yes
these are the people that can get those
complaints about ball hair out of your
life boy this is a 180.
yeah um but you know
but here's the thing here's what i've
discovered yeah because i got this
package in the mail right did you i do
it they sent me some stuff
um honey i'm going in the bathroom give
me leave me alone
i was also incredibly uh both impressed
and dismayed and somewhat inspired by
their willingness to use the word balls
in describing stuff
right here in the copy alone generally
when you do ads on podcasts and we've
been doing that for quite some time
you are told like in in very bold
heading do not
curse use words that are unpleasant or
something like that
it's so refreshing to see so much copy
um with listen to this man the uh
uh that's why manscaped has redesigned
the electric
trimmer the manscaped engineering team
spent 18 months perfecting the greatest
ball hair trimmer ever created and just
released the new and improved
lawnmower 3.0 have you ever wanted to
put a lawnmower near your balls
manscape's gonna make it happen for you
man when i tell you this is premium
i mean premium the battery will last up
to 90 minutes so you can take a longer
shave
and fellas if it's taking you 90 minutes
to trim your ball hair
then you're not trimming ball hair
you're masturbating or see a doctor
yeah that as well what is the uh
what comes in the kit um well it was a
lawnmower
it was some lotions some ball lotions
what was that like
uh i haven't used them because i'll tell
you what i use the trimmer for okay
i haven't visited a barber in a while oh
look at you
and so like if you're going to give me a
sort of high-end
cordless shaver you went for other areas
you're like
my balls are fine right now like we're
all good down there but up here needs
some attention
good to know so it's it's you could use
it for more than your
ball you can you can use it for your
biggest ball
the the testicle of your brain ladies
and gentlemen manscaped you don't know
how much we needed you to come along
right now oh my god you saved us from
being very very sad
um their third generation trimmer
features a
cutting edge ceramic blade you had a
ceramic blade
next to your head and six um and that
means you'll have one next to your balls
if you go for this um they released the
new lawnmower
3.0 man um the blade
what is it it's waterproof man that's
what i was reading right here man they
could actually
the waterproof technology allows you to
groom in the shower
i mean that's the time to do it it feels
messy
but while you're there and also let's be
honest
like it's the safest place in the world
to do it in the shower because you know
you'll take a shower get out be talent
off and be like
maybe and you'll put your leg up and the
moment you go
do your first stroke up the door opens
and somebody's gonna be like oh
hello i'm just trimming my balls yeah i
see you've been manscaped
very good uh the one of the coolest
features is the led light which
illuminates grooming areas
for closer and more precise trimming do
you ever want to look real close at the
pores that hold your ball hair
or trim your nets in this in the dark
yes
which is that's probably how you want to
do it turn the lights off because
manscape's got a little light right on
it's going to show you what you need to
see
you don't need to see anything else like
your confused dog's reaction
or your wife's displeasure they've also
upgraded to a 7000 rpm motor with
quiet stroke technology you know that
means it's a vibrator for men
press it against uh something and watch
other things happen
yeah yeah and let's not forget about
that charging stand mark
show your mower off loud and proud
because this intelligently designed
stand is a convenient charging dock
powered by usb man so when people come
into the bathroom like what's that
you're like what's that
why that's what i shave my ball hair
with it's my manscaped
bathroom living room table my friend
it's an obje dart this could you could
keep this in the kitchen
it's so beautiful and because it's
waterproof you can wash it i love their
catchphrase trim that junk of yours your
balls will thank you
no doubt man get 20 off and free
shipping
with the code you guessed it fat man all
one word
at manscaped.com that's man
escaped s-c-a-p-e-d dot-com
man your balls like mark said they're
gonna thank you get 20
off and free shipping most important
thing in this world
uh with the code fatman manscape.com 20
off free shipping at manscape.com if you
use the code word
fat man we thank the good folks at
manscaped uh for sponsoring us tonight
thank you indeed and well one of us
thanks you more than the other
i did you see this [ __ ] clean ass
head and next week i'll thank you after
i'm gonna shave my balls
do it you know what i'm 50. it's time
treat yourself
i mean let's see what see if life gets
any better you know
maybe that's been the problem all this
time you haven't been as aerodynamic as
possible maybe that's why i'm so heavy
too much ball hair
gotta lighten the load can you weigh me
without the ball here please
this could be the difference but you
know everyone at the beginning was just
like well shakespeare wrote [ __ ] this
in the quarantine and [ __ ] this could be
what i've been waiting for
you know everyone's always like man your
movies used to be good i'm like well
[ __ ] maybe this is what i need to do
zip get a little lighter
and suddenly i'm making a matrix how do
you unlock your creativity
manscape there's your new tagline are
you trying to write the great
american novel manscape that [ __ ] unlock
your creativity unhair your balls
so many taglines oh we could do this all
day um
man oh man well prior to this uh
breaking bad news did we have any news
we have plenty of news there's a lot of
things going on there's some things
going on man
let's let's let's
let's distract ourselves with news shall
we um i think because i'm feeling my
mortality as i'm sure you are as well
indeed how old are you i am 48.
and i'm 50. and this young gentleman
just passed at 43.
that puts things into perspective for
gentlemen of our age
suddenly you start going like wait a
second he was in great shape
seriously gentlemen of our age and
gentleman of our general physical
condition
it's like that dude paragon of animals
us little doughy if if
yeah we're not long for this world
that's what i'm getting at
so while we're here let's spend our time
wisely
talking about other people's projects
indeed
what do we got mark mark here went and
got some news for you ladies and
gentlemen
some good news probably some good news
or some news that's probably not as sad
as the news that we opened with indeed
we have a couple pieces of follow-up
um which is a thing that we probably
should do and never do every once in a
while
every once in a while um the first one
is
um it's it's an audio visual clue
um we talked about the batman
trailer the the the batman the trailer
yes the the the what do they do what is
it called on jeopardy when you get a vid
is a video gym no when they put up a
clue and you got to watch something or
see a picture
i think it's a it's like a video daily
double yes
this is our video daily doubles well
it's our it's not quite video yet but
um there was a shot in the trailer um
where somebody sent like a dead person a
birthday card
yes and the birthday card was like to
the batman and it opens it up and it
asks a question there is a
cryptic glyph code in there there's a
cryptic glyph code
um as we see on there it is the ass
screen thanks to jc and andrew we don't
even have to
give you a word picture they gave you a
real picture they really did
um because the internet being what it is
it did not take somebody that long
to solve that code someone read it then
went to read it
and then solved it and then solved it
and was like let me tell you what it
means
that's crazy um can you imagine i talked
about this with ralph on hollywood
babylon
could you imagine how frustrated poor
matt reeves must be because
you know it's like when he was writing
the movie he's like oh he got it look
we got to com it can't just be like
what's black and white red all over
these riddles got to be [ __ ] crimson
man they got to be like zodiac [ __ ]
deep and stuff
and built riddles into the script and
was like ah
you know they wait till they see the
movie then they'll figure out the riddle
audiences even wait until they see the
movie they're like he he lies still
yep is that what it was that's exactly
what it is the so the
riddle was what what does a liar do when
he's dead
and so the answer is he lies still
um but yeah i mean liz i could walk you
through the ways that this dude this one
the one
that i sort of caught into was by a guy
named mike selinker
anchor not sure but um and he's a
puzzler he's a dude who kind of like
writes puzzles for games and for both
video and
and sort of text-based games and he uh
he brute forced his way
through this puzzle which is he assigned
each one of those
uh glyphs a numerical figure okay
and then through that began to say all
right well all right listen if the last
two letters the last two symbols
are the same symbol and that same symbol
appears earlier on in the puzzle
than words that that have sort of
repeating
then you can start assigning then you
can start assigning it's like well it's
either going to be
it's like as like it's not crazy imagine
it's a d
f or an n but no it's not going to be
mafia stiff so unless
gorilla grodd is in the movie it's not
those options and then putting aside
rupee and puree
there are only five letter strings that
end with e e three agree to c
three would make the first word rt but
that's weird so it's not 3 and then 2c
but are you taking us inside the
puzzler's mind i was going to
realize that was a full narrative right
there where i'm like i think we're in
the puzzle
that was literally 5 out of 12 tweets
that this dude sent down explaining his
methodology
for how he gets to he lies what a piece
of work is man
you know what i'm saying i think someone
in the world bothered to take this much
time to be like oh i saw the riddle
that's in the movie that we won't see
for a year you know but also there are
dudes
for whom puzzles are fun that's true you
know and like i'm gonna crack this thing
just cuz
i'm gonna i'm gonna hack into norad see
what happens it's actually a pretty good
riddle too
it's not bad i liked it he lies still is
very like it's
double entendre he lies still and he
lies still and he still lies
um interesting little human uh human
interest story that one
isn't it though i wonder for us though
it's charming do you think for matt
reeves and warner brothers they're like
[ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] why do we put that in the
trailer why do we have to show the card
i told you not to show the card
somewhere somebody's getting yelled at
um still can't wait to see the movie
i've consumed that trailer
a number of uh times i had an
interesting conversation uh
the other day we did remember we did my
birthday drive-in thing
on my birthday so we raised close to 10k
and we donated
that money to the la food bank um one
dollar equals four meals so we bought
like 33 000 meals or something like that
and then we were distributing the meals
at uh hollywood bowl the parking lot and
stuff
cars come in you fill up their trunks
with food and so
it was me and jordan and julian and um
taylor and luke and chelsea so six of us
from spotco and stuff
so after a little while somebody i guess
word got out like oh my because we're
all in masks
but one somebody was like oh my god are
you him and [ __ ] so somebody from
l.a food bank came over and they were
like oh man it's really nice that you
guys did this and
nice that you come out and and uh
volunteer time and stuff and i was like
this is fun we live right around the
block so this is great if you guys do it
again we're doing a heartbeat and stuff
and so we chit-chatted about this about
the la food bank and stuff
and then like he's like i'm gonna let
you go before i get out of here he's
like
what'd you think of the batman trailer
and i was like you know i really [ __ ]
went for it i said i've watched it
like 10 more times since last weekend i
keep looking for
details and i was like and the thing
that i'm most transfixed by now
is colin farrell penguin where i'm like
you couldn't have just hired a [ __ ]
fat guy like you had to
you had to create makeup that amazing
where most people even
did you see the story about uh who's jim
gordon jeffrey right
yeah he didn't even know that that was
colin farrell in the trailer
somebody asked him he was like that's
colin farrell really that's
crazy man um but anyway it's so nice
to see we're back in a world
where one of my favorite um like
offshoots of whatever i do for a living
whatever it is i do for a living is
random strangers going what do you think
about
and i get to talk about like [ __ ] a
trailer or a movie i love or look
forward to with a total [ __ ] stranger
you want to talk about
bringing the world together and that's
all across the spectrum man
it's like naturally it's a lot of like
you know geeky [ __ ] kids and stuff
but it's like grown ass adults who work
at whole foods and stuff like that
people you wouldn't necessarily
suspect or whatever um but it's one of
the benefit of being a professional nerd
as opposed to like a dentist
yes where if somebody wants to come up
and like talk about work with you
so true it's just i know right let's
talk about robo tech feel like
i've got this [ __ ] abscess and it's
real bad and [ __ ] and i'm sure the
dentist is like [ __ ] man if i have to
talk about abscesses one more time
brush your [ __ ] teeth you know but
instead floss [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] it ain't my problem instead we
get to meet people who are like
and it's not even people calling us up
on the carpet like why'd you [ __ ] up
batman
they're like what do you think about
batman coming out i'm like i think good
things
how about you it's nice to get all the
enjoyment of the thing without like the
pressure like poor george lucas
you know we all know he walked away from
star wars because he was like
they yelled at me like i made what i
wanted to do i created their childhood
and then they yelled at me
so [ __ ] it it's not worth it and [ __ ]
uh yeah so that that i feel i do feel
like you said bad for matt reeves
you know maybe he and a crack team of
cryptologists were like
and by the way don't feel too [ __ ]
bad for matt reeves looks like he made
one of the greatest batman movies we're
ever gonna [ __ ] see
and also made a batman movie yeah yeah
we're all jealous he's like you feeling
bad for me
for me i'm [ __ ] matt reeves
i got monkeys in the back yo i got
planets of apes
um boy that movie looks good man but you
know the
now a week after fandom
it's uh you know the [ __ ] what is it
hangover time where you're like
oh man that was good i need a hair of
the dog that bit me you got any more of
that
batman and we're not going to see any
more batman for quite some time we're
going to have four years
in a bit we're going to have to make
that meal [ __ ] stretch man
did you see 22 million people tuned in
to the dc fandom
a definite hit what was unbelievable was
i saw some articles somewhere online
where somebody was like this was a
boring ass flop and i'm like well then
you don't know about business because
all i heard was enthusiasm and
excitement
um all i heard were other people going
like well [ __ ] marvel better do this
like a good idea is a good idea and
22 million tuning in to watch what is
essentially
one long-ass commercial for your
products that's qvc right there you know
what i'm saying like you're showing
people
here's some [ __ ] we want you to buy not
showing you out of the kindness of their
[ __ ] hearts going like
hey aren't we great they're going like
this is what you're going to spend on
get ready we're going to get you excited
and the money they would have spent
taking everything to san diego comic con
they put in their own backyard and
invented a thing
that will be one day god forbid but it's
gonna happen
we pass from this best of all possible
worlds they'll still unless there's been
a nuclear holocaust
and even then they'll still be doing
that dc fandom
because it was so [ __ ] unbelievably
successful and easy
yeah easy you want to talk about like
when you got a comic con you're like oh
we got to get people on a train or a
plane and get them there and put them up
in hotels and [ __ ] like this
this literally was like where are you
home great
go ahead we get gal gadot to run up to a
camera
we wear any out and then cover it and
then everyone jumps in and does their
cosplay did you see those videos yeah
it's really [ __ ] charming man i saw
some cats online [ __ ] on and i'm
like somebody was like
could you imagine if marvel made their
actors do this i was like it was fun
don't [ __ ] on them that'd be fun just a
good time man and
people got to be in a video with their
favorite actors the actresses from the
dc universe yeah
it's a great [ __ ] a great idea
i'm not surprised 22 million people
[ __ ] watch i'm not they should do it
every six months [ __ ] yearly yeah i mean
there is the open question
like does dc ever go back to san diego
in the same way that it used to
and who knows who knows about how much
of the real world
will return in the sort of post-colgate
lockdown phase
i think they're taking a page out of
disney's book with d23 man
like disney you know and marvel doesn't
have every year they don't feel the need
to go to san diego some years they take
off now because they're like we'll do
our own thing
yeah like if there's a year when it's
like the next wonder woman movie and
aquaman 2
and i mean all the jets they had stacked
up too
yeah just like you know what we're gonna
have our own thing
and you'll pay tickets you'll you'll
you'll buy those tickets and you'll come
you'll buy all the merch that's the
other thing that that dc doesn't do with
san diego same with marvel
yeah they don't sell merch they don't
sell merch they don't sell books they
don't sell anything it's just
all 22 million people watched if you
turn that into box office dollars say
the average ticket
maybe not the average but let's say
tickets 10 bucks a pop and stuff
was that 220 million dollars that's
it's a big opening weekend for a [ __ ]
movie right there totally a lot of eyes
all eyes on dc a lot of eyes um we had
mentioned last week
that there was a trailer that resurfaced
on the internet
uh how to make a blockbuster movie
trailer you brought it up yeah i brought
it up and i described it to you and i
feel like i did a shitty job at
describing it
um because it's hard because the blank
expression i have where i'm like
just shut up you're embarrassing all of
us this isn't good
yeah abort abort [ __ ]
so you brought it so i brought it i dug
it up on the internet and i found it and
we're bringing it to you
um and by the way we had a brief
discussion before the show began about
you know with chadwick passing away we
would love to showcase like let's watch
this favorite moment
let's watch this favorite moment but
after last week when you know we were
like here's a trailer that the entire
internet is playing
and then they literally pulled our
[ __ ] plug we're being a bit
you know circumspect about how much
footage we can use as we figure out our
ground rules here the thing about this
trailer there are no pictures glow
really yes amen so we get to watch this
we get to watch uh andrew let's what is
it called
it is called how to make a blockbuster
movie trailer and you roll that thing
a single note what is it or we're
establishing shots another single note
over most of them
have you ever wondered about this
particular thing
finished statement with mine i can't see
i'm fine
i'm an old man
studio vanity studio vanity card jc why
don't you read it you can see it
so put it in your mic so you can just
read it out loud for
me right now
big vfx show with wah that thing i
referred to
earlier you're not reading everything jc
but it will destroy us
someone has to stop this thing
and that someone is you think
i'm not the person who can stop this
thing you are that person
now take my hand the true boosh
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
and the reaction
exact release date oh that's
genius who made that i'm not entirely
sure
clever super clever and you know thank
you for your content
kind stranger and there's absolutely um
you know
plenty of superhero movie trailers
you've seen and or
transformers trailers you've seen
apparently there's a template
there's a hundred percent a template for
this and that's that
wow
that's what this show is true none more
booze
what's uh blah bouge what do we got um
you were an x-files fan yes of course i
named my first two dogs that i ever
owned in this world
scully and mulder so so if we had a
third one
at the time we would have named it
cigarette smoking man as well
weird name for a dog not skinner you win
a gun skinner i think
no probably not what do we get cigarette
smoking csm come here csm
come on ziggy yeah get in here ziggy
ziggy that would have been good
um fox is developing an animated x-file
spin-off
featuring the lone gunman um it is going
to be called
potentially um the x-files albuquerque
uh the new iteration joke show like
that's below decks
lower decks lower decks the new
iteration is an animated series about an
office full of misfit agents who
investigate the x-files cases too wacky
ridiculous or downright mopey
or dopey for mulder and scully to bother
with they're basically the x-files is
b-team
i mean i'm all i'll believe me i'll give
it a shot but like seems a little late
no
um yeah and it seems as if some of the
enthusiasm of the x-files was sapped and
dimmed a bit by the last two seasons of
the kind of
rebooted regenerated reconstituted
x-files
agreed um but you know it was only
as we were discovering with more and
more regularity
only a matter of time before ip like
this is
allowed to lay follow in the brand name
people know it they know the x-files
they feel like they can make a buck off
it have you watched the lower decks or
whatever it's called i saw the first
episode and
um it's uh it's a your star i only asked
cause you're a star trek guy not to put
you on the spot no i'm a star trek guy
it's it's a bit of a weird
thing in that it's like it's funnier
than star trek usually is normally is
it's not
as funny as rick and morty which it
feels like it kind of wants to be
so it lives in this kind of pleasant
middle ground like the orville
it's a bit like the orville but like
legit star trek in which the orville is
like
you know star voyage right
um so yeah it's it's it was pleasant
the the the half hour that i watched um
it scratched some
some like not un un welcome
let me ask you this as a fam where
you're like god damn it i should have
done this
um no i don't think so i don't know and
i think that it's
it's also not gonna do what um star trek
prodigy
which is the nickelodeon star trek
animated show what is that do we know
anything about that
we know very little about it except that
it's targeted squarely at children
really and right they gets designed to
try and build the next generation of
star trek fans by getting them when
they're young
smart um and i think that this this well
concepts to a kid
there's a federation it's made up of
planets
they got rockets kids like that [ __ ]
they do
i mean if they like trade embargoes yeah
don't talk about that
taxation tariffs yeah blockades those
kids could
lose lose it on that not so much the
inner workings of
the government galactic government no
we've got the senate
great senates are fun yeah boy that's
interesting
hey can you have a war now in the stars
i mean i showed up for a star war
or two of them plural yeah there's an s
on that thing
less delegates and representatives put
an essay on it i got an
ass on it what else we got
um that was a show that was going from
live action to animation
now here's a show that's going from
animation to live action segue let me
guess
okay powerpuff girls
yeah this was a strange announcement
this week when i saw it on the page as a
true
uh powerpuff girls fan i was like i get
it
i personally would don't want to do that
myself
like because i you know they were so
sweet and pure you don't need to make
that postmodern or whatever
but i'll tell you who [ __ ] went
through the roof was my kid yeah
my kid is a massive powerpuff girls fan
still has like framed
uh cells in her room so when she read it
and the premise of this powerpuff girls
show is they're in their 20s
and they lost their childhood fighting
crime
so they're kind of bitter about it but i
assume they'll still be fighting crime
right will they reunite once again now
that the world needs them more than ever
i mean do they bring back mojo jojo i
mean they bring back
a professor what is it professor utonium
professor utonium yes in the mysterious
chemical x
yes chemical x uh she went nuts for it
she was like i must be on this show
um i you know it is one of those shows
where who's writing it
um it is being written it's from the
greg berlanti factory of telling is it
really
so it's a greg berlanti sarah schechter
um joint
um and executive producer heather renier
i'm going to pretend i'm pronouncing her
name right okay um
and diablo cody that's what when i first
heard the story and i heard diablo's
name i was like oh
i bet you that has a good shot man she's
incredibly talented
i mean in in a world in which riverdale
can kind of make the jump from comics
and even even like the shift from the
archie comics that we grew up on
to the archie that like mark wade helped
rebuild for archie comics
right and then riverdale like and
riverdale is batshit crazy
in sometimes the best way and often like
what
is happening but these things are
elastic in ways that perhaps we hadn't
given them
credit for maybe it's us right maybe
it's us i mean
it's us we think a thing is a thing and
it's so strange because
we've had multiple incarnations of a
batman multiple incarnations of this
character that character
and yet still we're like you know my
first instinct was like you can't do
that with powerpuff girls
well i think the thing that we as you
know nerds want
is give me the version of the thing that
i loved in one medium
in a different medium yeah so it's like
it's always about fidelity right it's
like oh that batman isn't the batman
from the comics or man the captain
america never would have done that in
the comics
but this the very premise of it is
advancing and warping and shifting
things
and so that i think is maybe where
there's a little hesitation
but there's a generation like your kids
who's like [ __ ] it twist it warp it give
me something new
it was her reaction she was like that is
brilliant remix it
as long as the notes are the same but
it's a totally different instrument
bring it to me
remix remix um i will look forward to
watching the cw show
cw show um them stepping well i mean
river
riverdale was a step outside of the dc
universe and this is a
another step outside of the dc indeed
indeed indeed
man he's got something like 75
television shows on the air
i mean can we get one just one will be
cool come on just give us one of his
shows
uh good for him man um i i've liked
playing in his sandbox which sounds way
dirtier than i meant it
but i've liked i've loved going to flash
and
supergirl he's doing the lord's work man
making shows that we're like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me they give you
money to make that show yeah really
his [ __ ] lineup of shows seems like
it's his it's always his birthday
like it's just like oh my god this is
fun oh you got that job too
forever oh for me you shouldn't have
um [ __ ] all right well i'm on board i'll
watch that
um speaking of ip that
is not allowed stepping back to the
powerpuff girls
do you think they change them
three little white girls um it makes
more sense to
diversify no if you're telling that
story it would
but i mean if if they are going to be
called
like blossom and buttercup and bubbles
and bubbles i feel like they still need
to be
those kids that we saw um but then again
like there's lots of people who have red
hair there's lots of people who are
brunettes
feels like if you're going to reinvent a
thing right
reinvent it i mean and anybody was like
come on they're not they're all the
powerpuff girls were white it's like
all the powerpuff girls weren't 20 year
olds who were bitter about being the
powerpuff girls either
we're obviously obviously in new
territory so let's expect times have
changed they've been through some [ __ ]
yes so
let's let's let's welcome it there uh
i'm gonna do a deep [ __ ] dive into
star trek
but um in the classic series the
klingons
were basically just dudes in brown face
yes that's how they made that happen
they weren't they didn't have lobsters
on their heads they have the [ __ ]
ridges on their heads they were kind of
like
um romulans very much so it because they
had but so much makeup and there was
going to be a gorn at some point and
that's where a makeup budget went
and then on the next generation you
introduced the [ __ ] ridgeheads
and there was an exchange between wharf
and somebody else when um
it was on deep space nine and they
travel back in time to a classic next
generation episode
and wharf is standing next to an actual
legit like
60s klingon and uh and i want to say it
was like
avery books as captain cisco who was
like what
why are you both clinton and he says we
don't talk about that
and so maybe there's the like didn't she
used to be a little white girl
we don't talk about we don't talk about
that did um
uh speaking of uh um
[ __ ] that we oh this is a segue from
nothing i was just
speaking of a [ __ ] we talked about last
week which we didn't i finally watched
um lovecraft country [ __ ] is it great
isn't it wonderful i mean i'm telling
you you told me
i'm like mark you gotta watch this show
i discovered mine i heard from a friend
it is so [ __ ] unbelievably good and
that chase that you described
was absolutely beautiful they didn't
they wasted
no [ __ ] time introducing you to
lovecraftian concepts and characters
like when i watched that trailer i was
like i'm probably like
episode four we'll hear a lot of noises
in the woods until maybe we see
a cthulu type thing in the middle of it
[ __ ] opening
opening scene and then you know the
scene is a dream so like all right all
right but then once they get into the
story proper
they're unleashing night beasts and
stuff like that it was it's [ __ ]
intense it's really well done
and i liked uh journey smallett in uh
in birds of prey but she's [ __ ]
wonderful enough she's a firecracker
yeah and she's also in um with the uh
with uh misha in uh underground as well
but i mean and she's she's one of those
actresses who
should have been given lots more chances
at bat
not that she hasn't worked she's worked
relatively steadily yeah but she was
what she was on [ __ ] full house when
she was like four or five she was in eve
she's like a child actor yeah
um and she just brings it like all of it
she's so great it's special it's [ __ ]
louis
and it's also like once again hbo like
[ __ ] given an education
to american students who didn't get
educated
in american schools as you learn all
sorts of new stuff man it's
really well done spooky and also like i
mean i don't want to spoil anything but
like the end of episode two i'm like
oh we're moving on yeah like we're going
elsewhere
in the second episode is is for me not
quite as effective as the first
um and i think because it's it feels
like they put
four or five episodes of tv into the
same episode of tv
yeah so like a lot of [ __ ] happened
there was a bunch it happens fast
um but there were just these moments
where like
there's this great opening sequence
where suddenly everybody's kind of like
living in their best life
and moving on up they use the song
jefferson's and you're like this i love
the you know the sort of anachronistic
use of music they've done that a few
times done a few times
um and yeah there's there's a joyous
moment man because when the episode
began and they
started playing that song like i was of
course you know able to sing every
[ __ ] lyric
and my wife was on the couch and she was
like how do you know every lyric
to the [ __ ] jeffersons i was like i
watched it incessantly
i said really the question is how do you
not know every lyric to the jefferson
yeah like where where was your chair was
three channels and this was the show you
watched it's a deluxe apartment in the
sky
how hard is that to remember um but yeah
great stuff man how many episodes are
doing um i think it's
ten i believe it's [ __ ] jj and jordan
man
yeah can i have a little bit of that
talent and and [ __ ] misha
green just like wrestling it all to the
ground it is and i never read the book
but the book is
that was my question is in the book
is it are they african-american
characters they are
because that's i've read there was i
don't know where i've watched a video
afterwards and something and somebody
was talking about
like passing this book passed around a
lot
and the people it was being passed
around to like were black and i was like
well then it must be that because
the author is white yes so i was like
wait a second so did this guy
write white people or did he write black
people and did they did misha change it
or
did was that what it was and it turns
out that's the source material
yeah i mean i think that and and it's a
it's it seems to be
an interview with the guy and he was
just like i designed this to be bought
yeah like he said he was very upfront
he's like i came up with this thing
i i wrote the script like i wanted it to
get made and it got picked up
you know with the book and then within
like two years became a [ __ ] thing or
something like that but he was like
oh yeah like i'm i wanted this to be
something
not just like oh i love you know him and
stuff like that yeah i mean i think the
the embroidery of
the work that misha is doing is because
the book is like interconnected short
stories yes
and so is trying to make a somewhat
linear story out of it
so all so the book is unrelated it's
just bang bang i think
some of the characters kind of come in
and out and bob and weave but each story
is separate and unique
unto itself it's fantastic but yeah the
show i'm i'm i'm kind of in love with it
and i'm
even when like the second episode like
we talked about is a little more uneven
it's uneven for reasons of overreach and
yeah under reach
i agree like it's trying to do a lot and
and
i mean for me
[Music]
this is how i judge things that i like i
would never do that that would never
occur to me
holy [ __ ] that's really [ __ ] good um
tony goldwyn doing a good job playing
the creepiest white man ever
basically playing like old doc savage
yes yes that's what it felt like
the banana bronze um yeah it's good if
you haven't checked it out yet
the only drawback is that it's hbo so
they're
dishing it out right one [ __ ] serving
at a time so you can only watch two
right now but
um man they were worth watching and it
was i watched him back to back and it
was like
oh this is amazing nothing after that
where you're like no
and then try finding something to watch
in the wake of that for the rest of the
[ __ ] night
where you're like do shave your balls
gotta man you gotta get manscaped
when you're when you're like there's no
more [ __ ] tv to watch
jennifer's like let's watch the third
episode i was like not till sunday yeah
like eggs in a ziploc
um all right what do i got next um we're
talking about
if anyone's wondering i keep like
itching my [ __ ] foot i'm sorry
we got mosquitoes out here right we do
my wife's been trying to tell me for
like 20 years she's like they don't have
mosquitoes in los
angeles i was like then what bites me
yeah you need still water you know and
there are a fair
number of pools yeah there are new
mosquitoes out also in the last few
years
that are tinier and they don't go above
your knee they only bite your ankles and
your feet
it's a new kind of mosquito to los
angeles
an ankle mosquito it's an ankle mosquito
it's like a spruce goose of mosquitoes
like they don't fly that high off the
ground
like on the east coast in the midwest
you hear them in your in your ear
smack them on your arms but these don't
go these are like ankle biter mosquitoes
it's like a different little [ __ ]
ankle biters [ __ ] toddlers
i'm feeling it man uh disney is making
another haunted mansion movie
they should honestly like you know the
one they did do with eddie murphy wasn't
it
yeah and it's great like it's a great
concept great lore
um cool ideas when we were working on
the kingdom keeper series for disney
plus
um you know one of the episodes took
place entirely in the
haunted mansion and and was you know
there's so much
backstory that you could play with like
i could see that
yeah um katie dippold who uh who wrote
the heat
and wrote the the the heat like with uh
as well as the the ghostbusters reboot
is taking a whack
that one not so much but i love the heat
yeah
um and i think you know the the trick
is going to be at least according to
this article from deadline um
figuring out a way to make it both scary
and disney
because you know the problem with the
eddie murphy movie was that it wasn't
particularly scary it was just you know
flubber with [ __ ] ghosts and a black
dude
um god remember that whole yeah i could
probably sell
that right now with ghosts
i buy it i bought that pitch done
remember that there was that era where
eddie murphy did a lot of disney movies
yeah like just he wanted it it was like
nutty professor or he was in the family
right like after mulan
he was like firmly in scots until he
became
donkey and left to go to dreamworks [ __ ]
you
um yeah i'm i'm down for this i i you
know i
it's a cool concept you can get a movie
a better movie out of that
yeah i mean i'm i'm can i play one of
the hitchhiking ghosts
can i be ezra my bowler nah he's gotta
be thin i'll be the little guy it's like
i mean i'm i'm always suspect of the
sort of ride
to movie transition except like i really
loved the first pirates of the caribbean
movie that very
like the gold standard of ride to movie
transition
because at the end of the day it's not
about whatever was in the ride the ride
is like oh it's about pirates
in the caribbean yeah we just took the
names and we did our own thing yeah so
haunted mansion
i get how that works good work a little
less excited about jungle cruise but
that's just because i saw a
trailer for it did you see the trailer
yeah and
i uh enjoyed me
just like jesus i i've never
seen the rock look quite so perfunctory
there's there's a feel that it's and and
there's
part of it is he's playing a character
who's like going through this jungle
cruise
as if he's done it a million times to
get money out of passengers
right before emily blunt shows up and
it's like no i've got a real cruise
and like real [ __ ] gets scary but like
there's so much going through the
motions vibe
from the rock who has never looked like
a dude who goes to the moment no he
pours himself into everything yeah when
is this movie coming
um well it was supposed to be out this
year like everything else was do you
think it'll go to the app
um they're they're now saying it's next
july july through
so they're like oh we ain't putting no
rock movie on an app we're going to make
all the monies
yeah i think they're especially because
like it follows on the heels of uh
what's that
jumanji franchise right so yeah maybe
they'll be like oh we'll get some of
that
they're all hoping everybody's hoping
for some of that sweet jumanji money
every morning i wake up and i dream
about some of that [ __ ] jumanji money
i
think i'm hearing the drums or jumanji
two how many did they make so far
they've made jumanji and jumanji the
next level so there's only been two
there's only
so they've got they got a [ __ ] the
end of the trilogy is coming one day
jumanji the last jedi we got a lot out
of that
yes rise of jumanji
what else we got mark um one of the
things that came out
it's technically dc related but did not
break at the fan dome
okay broke just after the fandom is uh
their sort of upcoming roster
of new dc animated movies oh yeah why
didn't they break that effect um i'm not
entirely sure but you know or maybe it
was something that was supposed to be
part of fandom and they had
last minute sort of shunted off a bunch
of the panels
into a different event that's going to
happen in september
including one that i moderated um
deathstroke
knights and dragons yeah um which you
know hey whatever
that's fine it's their stuff they can do
what they want with it right but ign had
a like a superman man of tomorrow panel
on the sunday after fandom
where they said they are doing a bunch
of movies including
um superman man of tomorrow which is
already on digital um
batman's soul of the dragon oh that's
the 70s batman that bruce tim's doing
uh-huh that's cool um justice society
world war
ii oh and
batman the long halloween yes i saw this
now how exciting is that
and they're gonna do it in tim sale
style um i
got i hope so i hope so it's so
beautiful yeah
very distinctive yeah very i mean i i
don't know how that style
translates to animation but it's
gorgeous and it's going to be a
two-parter in the same way that the dark
knight
returns was i wonder if uh they'll be
able to
get jeff to write it he's not a marvel
anymore he's not a marvel anymore and
you know
he's done it once he certainly knows the
screenwriting and
he certainly knows that story very well
indeed that's exciting man
that's that's a good a it's a good one
to make particularly if they keep it in
sales style
yeah i mean and i i haven't caught up
with as much of those as i probably
should
but i am i'm rather impressed that they
it's it's a business for them
the movies yeah yeah yeah the animated
movies and they're all done with
care yeah when i watched the the death
stroke one i was like oh [ __ ] this is
pretty good
because i haven't literally seen one
since we we did a commentary track
you haven't been keeping up with them
yeah i haven't been um and yeah they're
still they're still making them they're
still making them good and
bloodiest [ __ ] they're grown up man
they're grown up
i mean you're talking about the company
that makes that harley quinn cartoon
which
is pretty darn grown up itself i which i
do love so much oh it's so good
that's the one i'm telling you that i'm
like man why didn't i think of this
batman [ __ ] characters cursing like
that
was born to make that show he [ __ ] bats
i don't [ __ ] bats i don't [ __ ] bad what
uh what do you got now
um westworld
was based on a michael crichton book it
was same guy that wrote jurassic park
indeed in fact a lot of people when they
saw jurassic park said oh it's westworld
with dinosaurs
it kind of was precisely um michael
creighton also wrote a book called
sphere
yeah yeah they made a movie of it once
they did yes with uh dustin hoffman as
an action hero yeah
and uh peter coyote was a mysterious
government dude and
sharon stone was a biologist
um i want to say sam jackson was in it
um
probably and now
i'm right sam jackson i'm sorry blowing
out anybody's earbuds right there
you nailed it um are they remaking this
thing they are making it into a tv show
by the guys who do the westworld
television show
oh what so nolan so brother
jonah nolan and lisa joy um and it's
also being written by
uh denise tay who's an executive
producer and writer on westworld itself
who's going to be the show runner
and team downey is involved so rdj is
going to get a little chunk of this
and rdj they just did uh perry mason
right yes
and they're doing andrew in the back
yeah yeah they do
love your favorite show that's ever been
and ever will be i came close to
watching that
this week finishing it my wife was just
like perry mason i was like
not yet we had just watched
a lovecraft country and i was like it's
not going to come close so
let's let's not i'm hoping for like a
mild too kind of lay me up for a while
we'll get there i watch two episodes
i'll watch the rest but
andrew swears by it yes somebody needs
to i i haven't seen it i've heard also
good things yeah i've heard nothing but
good things too but uh but yeah man i
i ain't got that kind of time um what
else you got
the king's man is not going the way of
mulan
oh the the king's man the prequel the
prequel to the king's men
um it was supposed to open on september
18th yes uh
no that's not gonna happen now september
september i remember that month that's
when the quarantine began
pretty much february 26 2021.
so they're really they believe in this
enough to be like people will come out
for it you know i mean i think who's the
star
ray fiends ray fines um
and some very handsome english dude who
i've never seen before
which seems to be the way that kingsman
movies work which is taran edgerton
nobody had seen before and then that was
his no but that was before the whole
world collapsed
that's true i don't know if like uh if
if um
let's say you liked the first two
kingsman movie which i did yeah totally
fun
but this is the prequel with none of the
characters you really know correct
and they're asking you come out in a
world you know where we still don't have
a vaccine well maybe by then we'll have
a vaccine or something
i just don't i don't know if i was in
charge i'd be like let's stream that one
i mean i think we're we're we're
beginning not just not to dismiss it
like it's
unworthy cinema but just in the world we
live in right now
is that the is that the mask worthy
movie that people are like i'll go out
and risk covered for this is that
tenant um it's not tenant you know i
don't think it's
a tenant tenant at this point you know
it's unclear
did andrew just say no he said no did
you see it
nobody's seen it nobody stateside has
seen it
good point i've read some people getting
on planes to go see it
which seems insane within country i
guess i didn't hear of anybody leaving
america to go see it because i don't
know if they
even let you into england right now yeah
everybody built a border wall but
wherever it's playing some people have
been like jumping on planes to go soon
tom cruise saw it i saw that video man
like where he was like
look at me at the movies you had me
at tennant
uh is that a dude trying to get a job
you think or it feels like that's a dude
who's just getting paid like
how much will it co how much will it
take to you [ __ ] me i mean you know
warner brothers paid him for that what
is it why what do they do they have any
connection with him on anything
tom cruise don't believe that i mean you
know they've made movies with him but
he's usually a paramount guy
never occurred to me that maybe it was a
you know like uh
i don't think tom cruise is out of the
goodness of his own heart
shooting himself as he drives up to
movie theater that part
that says tenant i'm going to the movies
guys it was
and then and also like talking to people
in the theater like afterwards and stuff
oh it's great
have you ever he's never worked with
nolan uh
no no no no no no
and maybe is he over there shooting
mission impossible that's why he went to
the movies
yeah so there you go he's like i'm over
there shooting or is in the whatever it
is like
that's a commercial for that movie yeah
and so warner brothers paid for that
commercial for that movie i think so
so what's that how much does tom cruise
cost to get him
to to be but knowing we could have got
him i would have paid him
hey i'm going to see jay and simon bob
reboot
i mean now you know he's got a price
yeah
everyone does everyone does now you're
just haggling for how much um
did he uh his review was just like it
was great it was his rig
have you read any reviews yet um i read
a couple hollywood reporters review
was um kind of sour sour to mixed
varieties was better you know i think
that the general consensus is
it's gorgeous and also confusing and a
little ponderous
sounds like a nolan movie andrew from
the back sound thank you
from the soap mines i know really a
little salty back there
um nobody seems to have said yet oh my
god it's worth almost dying for
right but if you live in a place where
you know
science rules and you can actually go to
the theater
it's like hey cool that movie was fun
especially movies are cool hey cool
science rules sooner or later we'll get
it
we will what are they doing for us did
they say yeah um
for l.a yeah do they move it it's like
do we have a release date
we we don't have an opening date yet i
think san diego is opening before we
will
san francisco will open before we will
um but we are still sort of counting by
county and
we're still we're still a ways away no
tenant for you
no time wear your mask be good go get
some tenant yeah i mean i wonder if the
dividing point for disney between
kingsman and mulan
is literally they know oh wait i'm sorry
kingsman is a disney movie now it's a
fox movie so now it's a disney fan oh my
god i forgot
you're absolutely [ __ ] right yeah and
they
still are like yeah we think people will
come out and see it
well i mean they're pushing it six
months and hopefully by the beginning of
next year but i think that
they don't like mulan has a massive
children's audience built into it
and parents will pay the 20 30 bucks for
that
in a way that like i would pay 20 bucks
to see
the kingsman but the numbers are not as
overwhelming right
between them no but not everyone is as
stupid as we are not everybody
will pay 20 bucks to watch it um
interesting however uh today as we are
taping
is opening night for the new mutants
it's happening now yeah yeah after all
this time
it's in theaters today so if i wanted to
after this i can go
no we don't have movie theaters aren't
open well there's drive-ins
that are showing in oh is that right so
i can go [ __ ] check out the new
mutant instead of driving if i wanted to
there are still i think in smaller towns
that aren't nearly as
badly hit as major metropolitan areas
are it's still opening in some theaters
this movie's been delayed for a long
time as well
josh boone movie yeah i mean it's
projected to make something like eight
million dollars in its opening weekend
which would make it the highest grossing
movie
of the last six months is that right
also
like a lifetime higher gross than the
fantastic four movie
when you think about it indeed um yeah
well i've been looking forward to it but
this theatrical release just means that
it seemed like it was a formality in
terms of like their
contract this movie has to be released
theatrically or something like that
because it seemed like a no-brainer to
put this on disney plus
yeah it must have been a contractual
thing and to a certain degree
it's also probably a bit of cover
because
the movie is is not according to the
reviews of the people who've seen it
particularly good oh they've so they've
reviewed it too yeah i mean
critics didn't go to like i saw a lot of
press people going like we're not
reviewing this movie because disney
won't provide a safe environment to
preview the movie
and they won't they wouldn't send out
links so like listen we're not going to
go to movies and see it
um but yeah the the popular consensus
the vibe
on the street is not great and josh
boone continues to say
dumb ass things in public what did he
say um
most recently yes um he uh he did an
interview with io9
in which he talked about the casting of
sunspot
okay who according to the original text
created by a fellow named bob mccloud
sunspot was a was a sort of afro-latino
character from brazil
parents were rich came from wealth um
but that was part of the fundamental
foundation of character
and josh boone in casting was like
i don't really believe that this guy
wouldn't be white
it became a so it became a white washing
thing and
and uh the quote that incensed most
people was something to the effect of
i didn't really care about the racism in
brazil you know sort of light skin
versus dark-skinned
i was just looking for the best actor
and i felt and the one who could most
convey the silver spoon aspect of this
guy
and so we you know basically we opened
up a casting call and
this white kid walked in and he seemed
to be you know
he was really great maybe if we kept on
looking for a black person we would have
found somebody who was just as good
but we stopped he said that yes
i mean less is more in the interview
circus less is more in the interview
circuit
and then bob mccloud went on you know
the on the internets to give you this
cloud co-creator co-creator of new
mutants of the new mutants along with
what bill's abilities
and bob mccloud was like a they spelt my
name wrong in the credits
yeah it's like you had three years this
movie's been done yeah
that's i mean it's you know that's
it's a big part of that dude's life work
life's work right
and so they make a movie of it so you're
like oh my god how cool
and you know i got to get credited and
they
[ __ ] spell his name and they spell
his name that is you know and you know
he
and their errors happen in making movies
and there's like
thousands of eyes and stuff and not
everyone you know
probably is familiar with the creators
of the source material and know how
their name is spelled but still
that all being said it's no [ __ ]
excuse to get the name of one of the
[ __ ] creators wrong his name is gonna
be upfront in the credits
yeah yeah yeah and you know he he
similarly was not pleased
with the decisions to you know danny
moonstar wasn't really cast with a
with a particularly you know native
american looking actress i'm not sure
the ethnicity of
the actors they did cast and he also
went in about
sunspot and was like yeah but big part
of this character's identity and story
was the fact that he looked the way he
looked being from where he was from
and to strip that from the movie feels
like it's being disingenuous to what
this is all about
and so new mutants in theaters today
new mutants making friends and
influencing people left and right
uh i look forward to seeing it i won't
be going to a theater to see it but it
sounds like it'll be streaming pretty
soon
it would not surprise me if it was good
and i don't mean that
like a negative like oh it's gonna be
streaming because it's not good i just
mean
yeah the windows are shrinking at least
now we're closer to the release than
we've ever been before it's been [ __ ]
years so if
it's out in theaters guess what we get
to see it home soon yeah
um and our final story for the week is
uh the fate
of a little brand called fangoria oh yes
um pangoria when we were kids kids was
everything it was the internet before
the
you were a internet existed it was it
was famous monsters
and it was fangoria and also you know uh
famous monsters predates us by the
forest ackermann's magazine been around
forever as the granddaddy of
movie monster magazines but fangoria
embraced
like whereas famous monsters embraced
monsters
fangoria was like here's the blood
here's the [ __ ]
the the chainsaw killers here's the
[ __ ] slashers
um they were not afraid to show the gore
it was the penthouse
ii two famous monsters please yes
where are they these days i understand
they had a
moment where they were bought by a
company in texas
and that dude who runs the company
turned out to be not a great person
yeah i think they they had some some
unfortunate
owners over the the course of the last
few years
um but uh but they have since been
bought
now by a wonderwall entertainment who
is bringing it all back bringing back
fangoria as a magazine as a print
magazine
has plans to do something with
fangoria's corporate siblings
which were gorezone which was even
gorier than fangoria
and starlog which actually starlog yeah
which predates fangoria by a couple of
years it does starlog is over
the internet before the internet existed
indeed star log was fangoria for scifi
fans
indeed and i i worked at starlog my very
first job out of college
the [ __ ] out of here editor for starlog
magazine and my name appears
probably in a good um
30 or 40 issues of fangoria as a
consulting editor because
the edit stats were so small everybody
read everything so
so you got to be in a bunch so i got to
look at you man
i know um so fango coming back fango's
coming back called it back in the day
fango star log coming back um i will
start
gone apparently there's going to be
starbursts still publishes in england
they do and they've been publishing
longer longer than star log even
fangoria studios fangoria podcast
network fangoria digital
starlog digital and gorezone digital in
2021
and fangoria studios is aiming to
produce and distribute both fiction and
non-fiction content across all platforms
i would make a movie for those cats
indeed and [ __ ] fangoria that'd be
awesome to see that name at the
beginning of your movie
and they are they're sort of focusing on
championing new and diverse creators
oh then that's not me at all i'm old and
white i will be surprised
those things he said i will be
supporting the work of these young and
diverse creators
um but that you know it makes a ton of
sense yes
at this point like that's that is a lot
of where the money is that is a lot of
where the eyeballs are i saw a story
similar to that this week they announced
that orion is coming back
and that orion is going to be chiefly
diverse films
like filmmakers who've unsung have not
had their voices championed or
platformed before
i mean it's smart because that's a
well-known name and and you know why not
it's just sitting there as a division
why not like
towards something and it feels like we
are we are kind of slowly cr
crawling ourselves back to where we were
in like 1990
when like home video gave birth to this
blossoming of sort of low to mid-budget
african-american movies like it was a
sort of second exploitation and you get
rusty cundiff and you get house party
and you get boys in the hood and you get
like
this to society yeah like all of it was
driven
by home video like home video like we
can sell it if you put a black person in
if they got a gun we'll sell it
and some of those movies got to be great
and you know
some of them got to be actual [ __ ]
high art some of them were just
exploitation like everything else was
and that's fine
but since that sort of heyday of the
early 90s
uh which stretched until like you know
new jack city
and kind of then finally got you all the
way up to blade
it all kind of that's gone away like
with home video that desire for
oh we can sell it if you can make it
it's the thing that made horror work so
so easily like oh [ __ ] it if you can
honestly the reason why
my career went as long as it did wasn't
because of our box office theatrical box
office because home video
yeah we always sold very well on home
videos so they were like uh whatever
they don't do at the box office they
more than make up for in home video so
it i believe me i'm part of that without
home video
my career would have ended a long time
ago yeah and
you know people were willing to take
chances especially in genre
because if you delivered a certain thing
then the audience would show up for it
anyway
and then that's how you get your sam
raimi's and that's how you get your
[ __ ] like carpenter was a little bit
before then but a big fat middle of his
career
is like sure man i'll make ghosts of
mars referenced
rusty cundiff i think i just read that
they're doing tales from the hood
three or four like yeah because
again it's [ __ ] horror plus black
people
like it seems that that works and it's
also a pedigree and a known name at this
point too
yeah so it's it's i'm i'm encouraged by
the sort of orion decision and the
fengori decision because yeah fango is a
fantastic brand
and there's lots of love out there for
fango and to see them
sort of synthesize and and redirect that
love
into something new and exciting is new
and exciting and it's uh
and they're out of the hands of uh the
guy who was no
good or whatever right um how what a
happy ending for fangoria thus far
absolutely uh that's the end of the news
see you in the news my friend mark
gotcha news give it up for mark man
we're gonna dive to q a now ladies and
gentlemen before we do that
uh in case you've tuned in late um
the great chadwick boseman who played
black panther
passed away at age 43 we eulogized him
at the top of the show
we're talking about this loss and
whatnot comes out of nowhere for a lot
of us
a lot of folks online in the chat room
and before we jumped on the show tonight
uh feeling a little like lost and of
course upset nobody likes to see anybody
die particularly somebody we all
[ __ ] loved in a bunch of movies so
uh our hearts go out to his uh friends
his family his fans everybody affected
um by his loss it's a [ __ ] tragedy
way too young
way way too young with too many days
ahead yeah and
so much talent um all right we go to q
and a portion ladies and gentlemen the q
and a portion of the show
like the whole show itself sponsored by
the good folks at manscaped
trip your goddamn ball hair that's it
steven bows
um what do we got jc jc uh uh
owns this here uh drinking establishment
the scum and villainy cantina
uh he's sitting in the in the booth
where the owner sits
what do you got for us jason the owners
the owner's booth over there
uh that big fat nerd says one of his
earliest memories of a big eventing
comics was
marvel vs dc in the mid 90s
you're a pup uh he loved seeing green
lantern vs silver surfer
lobo versus logan capper's bat
it's the most epic thing he'd ever seen
he says it's a desperate it was a
desperate move by a struggling industry
how desperate did the studios need to be
to pull their ip into mcu vs dc
eu event film it'll it won't happen for
10 years i feel like
i think eventually i'll see that in my
lifetime before i leave this world
knock wood if i live long enough i think
they will do it but i don't think
marvel has any reason to even think
about they got
oodles of ip and characters they haven't
even touched
and they're making mints worth of money
with those characters why do they have
to go you know across the street to
[ __ ] around with dc so i don't see that
happening in for quite some time
um i think you know what we're going to
see is a lot of
dc kind of taking a page out of marvel's
book now with like a flash movie that
has
a bunch of characters in it from a bunch
of different other movies
but i don't think it i got to imagine
like while there's still
[ __ ] life blood in this [ __ ] like
they could still drain a nickel out of
their own ip without teaming up and
you know it's not like when you make a
deal with sony because you want to put
spider-man in your marvel movies that
makes sense like this is
[ __ ] massive it would be the uh the
biggest story the entertainment story
of the year and perhaps the highest
grossing film of all time
you want to knock end game off the top
spot dc versus marvel marvel versus dc
having to be a two-parter and the second
part is the amalgam universe
oh yeah i mean i think the only way it
happens
is if disney buys mark warner if
literally if if
at t and warner brothers decide to
offload dc comics
yeah and disney decides to buy it and
then it becomes
we're not colluding anymore we just
bought them
just the same way that like dark horse
used to publish
the aliens comics it has forever now
the aliens comics are going to be
published by marvel because marvel owns
[ __ ] 20th century fox and they're
like why would we
let's we own a comic book company we own
this character
put it in and they're going to do all
the reprints of the dark horse stuff and
then start telling their own stories
yeah i mean i think that you know to
your point big fat nerd
um it requires desperation and at this
moment you know neither of these
companies are desperate they're not
desperate enough
you know and so so yeah but something to
look forward to
the the cratering of an industry exactly
when all the money is gone yeah then
you'll get the movie you want to see
like if we were quarantined for like a
decade
you know and it was like how do we get
people to come back out
how do we get people back into movie
theaters when it might kill you while
you sit there
disney's like i know how to do it the
king's man
come on back for the whole refine
section are you sure you want to [ __ ]
invest that deep in the kings man
um but yeah i don't i don't like you i
don't see it happening
for a very very long time if ever unless
there's a massive change in who owns
what and when i'm
uh if you know hopefully i'll live
another 20 to 30 years and if that's the
case
they better get it done in 20 to 30
years that's all i'm saying
all right thank you big fat nerd what do
you got jc give us another one
uh dan sweet wants to know
uh he says his favorite character is
thunderstrike from the thor comics uh
he's an underrated hero he wants to see
him
uh live action in film or tv
who are your underrated heroes that
you'd like to see brought to life
i say this all the time and i will say
it until they finally do it the question
at dc comics like deserves
his or her own thing
a person whose [ __ ] mask is no
features
is unsettling and [ __ ] creepy this
person talking to you
and you don't see a mouth moving because
there is no [ __ ] mouth or eyes
like that i'm still
carrying the sign holding the torch if
you will they gotta do the question
sooner or later they gotta the closest
we ever came was warshark
in uh in watchmen but man oh man could
you imagine so i'm i'm all about
the question um what about you um i
i have wanted and i know movies about
this character exist
um and they're they're good but they're
old they were made in like the 70s early
80s
but lone wolf and cub i think is is a
massive deep cut um classic of the genre
like it is it is one of the
finest comic books ever published so
much so that it was stolen from
mandalorian
indeed hook line and i'm sorry homaged
in mandalorian um but i think that like
if you if you
legit made a lone wolf and cub tv show
and gave it game of thrones resources or
lo or [ __ ] love craft country or a
watchman
like an epic feudal japanese tale about
revenge and parenthood
[ __ ] all day long yeah all [ __ ]
day long so yeah
speaking of [ __ ] revenge and paranoid
you see the trailer for raised by wolves
i did it's a series i thought it was a
one-off movie but it's a ridley scott
[ __ ] series on hbo hbo the max
man they spent all the money too it
looks phenomenal yeah a bunch of
children raised
is that the first time he's ever done a
serial um i think i think scot-free is a
production company
so he's not directing this i think he
at the very least directed the pilot
right um i'm not sure how much of it
he's done but
they are absolutely saying from the
maker of aliens they are leaning in
gladiators and it looks
it too as you look at the scope you're
like but what um
do you know the source material is it
based on a book or kind of sure
i'm not sure it looks good it does look
good it does a good time man
in terms of like genre stuff like i'm
that lovecraft country coming on the
heels of like you know not too long ago
we had [ __ ] watchmen as well like
some really great [ __ ] out there
hell yeah um yeah lone wolf and cub and
the question
together in one
when you movie the question you kill the
question um they can't speak the same
language but they're both
fighting crime
i mean it's squishy um all right that's
two what about
uh the third and final jc what question
can we answer these fine folks
uh maya wallace was wondering miss mia
wallace
what what movies have you watched that
helped with grieving the loss of a loved
one
what a great question what movies have i
enjoyed while grieving the loss of a
loved one
or that helped you that helped me i mean
i still to this day whenever i watch
the world according to garp it makes me
think of my dad and
and um because he took me to see it when
i was like 12 and i was
way too young for this movie like
but he trusted me enough go like no
you're not like you can handle this
yeah there's a blow job in it and some
guy gets his dick bit off
just don't tell your mother it's good
family entertainment
yeah it's like this is a father's son
sometimes
dicks get bit off you keep your mouth
shut i'll take you a lot more of these
movies where
dudes get their dicks bit off i'm like
that's dad
um that movie um you know
i remember watching after my dad passed
away and it made me feel
a bit comforted um
that's the one that leaps to mind what
about you a great question though
yeah i mean i i tend to try to be
creative when
somebody passes away because that to me
is like you know raging against the
dying light if
death is destruction being creative is
the opposite of that that's what makes
me feel better
um i i don't have a ton of experience
with this
you have a lot of death both of my
parents are still alive
my grandparents died
over a decade ago you know and it was
never you know there was there was grief
but again 96 and 97
right it becomes at least for me in my
heart a little bit more celebratory
which is like that's a hell of a [ __ ]
run like you made it
long lives yeah long lives so i i have
never
really felt the uh the the sting
of somebody passing away perhaps before
their time i did have a friend
when i was 19 20 years old
who i'd known since i was a kid who died
at like 18 of a cerebral hemorrhage like
just one day just didn't wake up
[ __ ] um and i and i
ironically the thing that i watched in
the wake of his passing was the exorcist
because that was a movie that we watched
together far too young to be watching
the exorcist
you know it i i tend to i was watching
dudes get their dicks bit off you were
watching
girls screwing themselves with
crucifixes you know it's a
genital film festival yeah um but i
i it is less for me about
processing the trauma or the grief and
more about me
remembering the person same thing with
my dad you know and so
like how do i how do i pay tribute to
the time that we spent together then
let's
let's do the thing that we did once or
twice or four or five times
um i mean i think that that
and we had talked about this back in
march i think
the ongoing trauma that we're all kind
of feeling on a daily weekly monthly
basis of just
low grade low low key trauma which is
not enough to register like i gotta get
to
i need help but enough that it's just
this dull boo
in the background we're constantly
processing and processing in new ways
because it's never really fading and
she's always here
and for me that becomes a nostalgia
thing like going back into stuff that i
like and stuff that i love
stuff that makes me feel good um
television has been a boon for me in
that way
where it's like go back and just swim in
a show that you love and you can do so
for
months and months on end you know when
uh the west wing
has been a big bomb for me and so i was
very excited to hear that there's a
reunion coming yeah they're doing a
thing
they're doing a thing which so far kind
of rereading an old script or something
yeah they're doing a sort of live stage
performance of an older episode
and so they get the band back together
which is like it's awesome because that
you know i i felt that very acutely in
november of 2016
the desire to kind of live in the
idealism
of a government that seemed to function
based on very high principles
give me a tv president no another tv
president
give it a fake one there you go and
recently it's been battlestar galactica
which is like
oh all right you know this show can be
dark as [ __ ] but it's very much about
people
persevering right and doing you know
their best in impossible scenarios
um led by people who want the best for
them flawed
though they may be and overreach though
they might do
it's still also a quaint portrayal of
democrats and republicans
very much so where you're like oh
remember when they just didn't get along
like you know you know like yeah
ideologically
yeah it's like but we all we both want
the same thing we're just
gonna go about it different ways right
um which no longer seems to
sadly be the case um so yeah it becomes
a dip into fantasy sometimes real work
fantasy sometimes not
um but yeah it's nostalgia and or the
totem of the person
who passed brings them back for that
little moment in time
um if you're feeling blue uh movies
about death that like always made me
feel pretty good
in terms of like i don't connect them to
anybody particularly in my life losing
anybody particularly in my life but
um meet joe black oddly enough really
which has one of the craziest death
scenes ever which we see on twitter all
the time with brad pitt getting hit by
the [ __ ] car
but anthony hopkins has this really
wonderful line at the end of the movie
when um
spoilers it's about anthony hopkins
plays a guy who's
about to die and death comes to visit
him in the form of brad pitt and
it's like based on death takes a holiday
kind of thing where he's like i
i've come to take you but like you know
i'm going to give you more time
and you're going to show me you know why
life is so worth living and stuff i've
it's never occurred to me to ask why so
you know anthony hopkins is escorting
death around everyone's like who is this
guy
and stuff um he has this big shindig for
his 60th birthday at the end
and he's given the speech and he knows
at the end of this night
that they're leaving because death has
told him it's like we
we leave after the party so he gets up
and he gives this
you know powerful speech where at first
it starts very superficially
but then anthony hopkins like in
character of course
um stops talking
and oh my god it still [ __ ] chokes me
up it's so well delivered
it's a good line but it's [ __ ] sold
by a guy
who's an absolute master you know in a
movie that you wouldn't necessarily
think would have this moment but it is
about [ __ ] death the whole movie's
predicated with that
but and i'll never forget this line i
think about it all the [ __ ] time i
thought about it when i was on my
on on the [ __ ] table getting the
heart attack uh
getting the stent put in me and [ __ ]
during the heart attack he goes
[Music]
it's either 60 or 65. i want to maybe
it's 65 65 or
i want to say 60. he goes 60 years
didn't it all go by in a blink and i
[ __ ] still think about this
to this day a dopey throwaway line in a
movie that most people
never really considered past their first
viewing but i thought it was like
such a profoundly moving line like
the dude was standing there in front of
a bunch of people he knew like you know
the highlight
of his life [ __ ] his birthday and
rich people they eat flies and
helicopters and [ __ ] like that
and how he summed it all up what made
him very introspective was he goes 60
years
didn't it go by in a blink and you know
the
party's just like nobody's like get dead
[ __ ] like everyone's just like
kind of like oh that's
but they don't know what he knows right
so it's especially poignant because
you know it's not just a guy on his
birth they go oh it went by so fast
it's a dude who literally knows he's
about to die and he's like didn't it all
go by in a [ __ ] blank
so good um and what else oh you want to
feel good about [ __ ]
life and death or okay about death wash
you the last 10 minutes of
big fish by tim burton holy [ __ ]
you want to talk about a beautiful
ending to a movie man main character
gets to see all the people that meant
something to him throughout his entire
life
that's how we should all [ __ ] pass we
should all be so lucky that we get to
see
everyone who made us who we are before
we leave this world
[ __ ] that movie still gets me to this
day um
and that's not like the the obvious
choice right like it's not like nobody
goes like big fish will help you deal
with [ __ ] death
but art when done well nobody's ready
for this
nobody wants this like nobody heads
toward it and the people that
do intentionally mystify us because
all of us dream about staying in this
world as as long as [ __ ] possible
and to have a piece of art out there
that like
makes it okay even for a minute with
this
unavoidable profound and sad truth that
it
will [ __ ] end that you will end and
everything you love
stops eventually that's what art's about
i guess right
like to give you that moment in life
takes your breath away
makes you appreciate where the [ __ ] you
are in the story at that point in time
i'm sure
tonight because chadwick boseman passed
away
a lot of people are taking stock about
where they are
in their story right now so often we're
so busy telling the story and living the
story
that we don't think about the profound
miracle of everything it took to get you
here in the first place
we think about the [ __ ] we don't have we
think about the problems we have we
think about
how our lives have been affected by
coronavirus and stuff
and you know you tend to forget like
i can't even put my fingers close
together enough to show you how close
you had to [ __ ]
come to to to break into an egg as a
sperm
and beat all the other [ __ ] sperm and
live this best of all possible [ __ ]
worlds even when it's at its absolute
worst
so finding a piece of art that makes you
okay with the notion even for a moment
that like yeah one day it's gonna end
that helps you accept that and that's
what we got a lifetime to accept the
fact that this lifetime comes to an end
that's wonderful art those are two
movies that like you would not
think off the top of your head like oh
meet joe black
but man there's got there's moments in
that movie that say a lot about living
and whatnot and uh and for sure um
uh what was the second one i said uh
big fish big fish yeah those are two
yeah i mean it's in it's incumbent
on on people who want to make art
you know and then people will have all
kinds of advice like yeah if you want to
be a writer what do i do like what books
do i read what
i got to live a life you know like the
most important thing
is to be a part of the world that you're
trying to put into your art you know
and it's the only way people are going
to recognize it it's the
it's it's how we see ourselves in the
art is if you have lived a life
in all of it's [ __ ] up and and
wonderful
different variations and then can then
go and make art
informed by that you know and and
i remember you know hearing from damon
lindelof talking about the beginnings of
lost
that it basically was him processing the
death of his father
which had happened incredibly recently
to him sitting down and cranking his way
through the pilot
with jj abrams like they had a week and
a half to write a pilot
and it was well i just lost my dad and
i've never dealt with it and i'm also
having a lot of questions about religion
and i've never dealt with that
and so what is lost about it's about
jack shepherd
who's flying back from australia with
his father
to bury him in the states and like
it's about the baggage of a life that
you
don't know how to come to terms with you
know and and whether or not you think
that's what loss is about whether or not
that
becomes present or or vibrant for you
when you're
watching of it that's what was going on
with the dude who was talking about it
and the show is infused with that
and it's important that we live lives
because then other people can
recognize themselves in the art or even
just the life that you lead
you know nobody wants to sit down with a
robot has never done nothing
it's take it from a guy who once worked
at a convenience store a long time ago
in a galaxy far
far away and thought i don't know a lot
of people come into stores they might
recognize this story a lot of people
have jobs
they might identify and stuff it's it's
your born-ass [ __ ] life
that's the key like you sit around going
like oh i wish i was anything else
it's the normalcy it's how familiar we
are to one another it's our similarities
that make stories like that land as well
as they do
you know there are stories that are
satisfying to watch because they're fun
and [ __ ] like
end game and all the marvel movies and
[ __ ] some of the dc movies
but um then there are things that land
you know right here
and right here and wind up holding a
mirror up to us
where suddenly you know you're in the
midst of something i mean it happened to
me with [ __ ] watching flash
first season of the flash there's a
video of me bawling and [ __ ]
that's yes it's because flash is well
done and the story line was good
but that's everything i brought to that
exact moment
in time when i watch it from my own life
that's what's beautiful about this [ __ ]
we don't
sit around and talk about it because
it's like oh it's just
fun to watch it means something to us
it's the way we speak to one another
it's how we relate to one another
um yeah it's like people will always say
could you ever just turn your brain off
and watch a movie
it's like well no because i'm bringing
myself to it
and some movies will harmonize and
vibrate in a different way
but i can't be passive because that's
not how this works
yeah because we're active participants
in our lives and we're active
participants in the stories that we
intake because we're bringing our own
perspectives to it
and things that mean things to me and
things mean things to him will be
different
sometimes or similar in other times but
it's because we're bringing ourselves to
this work
and it's because somebody who made the
work is bringing themselves and putting
it on the screen
it's true it's like the makers and the
audience
invest more of themselves in this stuff
than you know other mediums because
we're all searching for a truth and you
know even though movies lie at 24
[ __ ] frames per second
there's truth hidden within them and so
moments that you see in movies that
take your breath away or actually make
you feel calm
about the inevitable calm about like you
know
like oh my god this will all stop one
day my i will lose my
parents i will lose my wife husband like
all all of this you know it it's he used
a perfect word before it's a sav
it's a bomb i think he said bomb um
there's a bomb in gilead ladies and
gentlemen
duck no a bomb b-a-l-m it's
uh to borrow a hackneyed expression from
20 years ago
chicken soup for the soul oh and that's
why we're all here that's why we gather
together not to ask the lord's blessing
but to talk about the things
that we love and the things that mean
something to us and
thank god over the course of the last 10
20 years
it's now it's more acceptable to love
this [ __ ] this much
you don't have to hide it you don't have
to be like well i go to star trek
convention
you know you could wear it on your
[ __ ] sleeve because the whole world's
embracing the stuff
that we've been embracing and this type
of genre storytelling for years
um you want to feel good about life
watch a movie
even a bad one because that'll make you
feel like i'm better than this
and make mike you want to be a filmmaker
and [ __ ] then your life gets real good
because then you get to make movies and
talk about movies and then one day you
get to a place where you're like
i don't really want to make them anymore
i just want to talk about it
that's where i am kids
great questions tonight right indeed man
we got some good chatter out of him man
it's a sad night ladies
and gentlemen but uh strength in numbers
and we got together and
hopefully lifted each other up for a
little while man how the kids doing in
the chat jc everyone happy
or yeah we're doing they're doing all
right now no
now what was the matter uh just a lot of
trollbots racists that i had to
holy [ __ ] yeah that's it's all
bought people with keywords
but i think we got it under control
sweet we had a lot of um
uh shawshank redemption also get
busy what a great point yeah get busy
living or get busy dying brooks
hollywood boulevard is jumping yeah did
anybody tell you that
uh we're we're quarantined here in los
angeles hollywood
we're not everyone out i i've been you
know i hike right in every morning
i'm not saying this to lift myself up
over anybody else
but me and maybe a third of the people i
see
wear masks everyone else no masks
i ain't judging i'm just saying like if
we all don't
treat this seriously we'll never get to
see
tenet there's a there's a line that has
been running through my head
for the last six months oh i know what
it is put your [ __ ] mask on
it's uh it's from hunt for october um
some things in here don't react well to
bullets not quite
it's uh it's it's uttered by fred dalton
thompson who would then eventually
become a senator
but uh he says something like this
situation will get out of control it
will get out of control and we'll be
lucky to live through it
jesus it's a little grim but every
[ __ ] week
i'm like god do you not what
how do you really remember there's that
great moment too and then
you know the one guy's like i don't i
don't care for the uniform i don't like
it and he's just like
he broke his back and [ __ ] and he goes
doctor went down
in the mid yeah he spent a year and uh
he spent a year doing annapolis from his
hospital bed
i don't know if it's me but i might cut
him a little bit yeah he's like i don't
know maybe it's me charlie but i might
cut the kid a little slack
now i want to watch that movie i was
thinking of that movie because of
courtney b vance who was in lovecraft
country but he's the one that's sitting
there
paganini paganini yes and talking about
and doing like he's the one that finds
the caterpillar drive he does
khan sonar crazy ivan oh [ __ ] i love
that movie god damn it
you had to say crazy ivan and now i have
to watch the movie
because he says it too he goes they call
it a crazy eye
he took crazy and turned it into three
syllables come crazy
i'll never forget that what a great
flick um did you have a good time
are you not entertained stolen from
another movie which i never
feel like watching never gladiator no no
i've seen it and i enjoyed it but never
once has it occurred to me to go back
and re-watch that movie
i uh i i used to do whatever really
scott's like well i never even saw clerk
so [ __ ] you
yeah quid pro quo
but i i used to watch it a lot when i
like first got
a [ __ ] home theater system and like
the first either the first gladiator
actual gladiator battle or the big
[ __ ] charge when they're in germany
or whatever but it's a workout for your
speakers
really um yeah and so that was that was
like a demo
thing it was like that at the beginning
of terminator 2 with the [ __ ] skulls
on this
robot yes or private ryan private ryan
was the the gold standard
because the opening sequence of that and
you got [ __ ] oh my god
and it's just a great mix yeah and it
look like it's a
non-stop mix for the first half hour of
that movie where it's just like
yeah everything's happening and then
like it goes underwater and something
you just hear that look
another war that i learned more about
from entertainment than i did in school
yeah no entertainment seems to be uh i'm
going to say it right here
thank god for hollywood because without
it i wouldn't know half the [ __ ] that i
know
and half of it is probably wrong and
incorrect and whatnot but still
i mean our knowledge is specious at best
yes
to say about the last thousand years of
history
but thanks to steven spielberg and and
damon lindelof
i know some [ __ ] now that i never knew
before in my life
um there it is folks thank you for
hanging out with us
uh here at the cantina strength of
numbers and we all got to
lean on each other for a little bit man
sad day for those of us who
love movies and particularly the marvel
movies and particularly
black panther chadwick boseman passed
away at 43.
uh real bummer man go hug somebody
indeed go call somebody you haven't
spoken to a little bit
and whatnot make some connections uh
that's what we do when when we lose
people man it's a reminder
it's the only there's no silver lining
comes out of [ __ ] losing someone you
love
except for a reminder of the fact that
there are other people you love
maybe you could be reaching out to as
well so let's all do that if we can
um there is no show
happening ladies and gentlemen without
the man on the other side of this spit
guard
and that's mr mark bernardin thickless
cage himself
how long do you keep that on your
twitter i don't know man but it's so
much fun
it makes me laugh every time i see a
thickolus cage
two c's no lessies um uh
come back next week naturally we'll be
talking about other stuff and whatnot
um if you're in the new jersey area on
monday i think we announced where the
movies pop-up is going to be
and i'll be coming out east for the
opening of that
um on a plane i'm not sure if i'm going
to
fly or drive i'm of two minds about it
number one if i get on a plane i can
take a red eye be in jersey in four
hours overnight
right but you know then there's you're
on a plane but
i also think that like all them airlines
is going to go out of their way
to make sure you don't catch covet on
their flight yes so that seems like it
could be safe
although you know driving you control
your environment
and you know that's just multiple days
be about four days get across country
but
i could get into doing that with jen
like driving four days listening to
music [ __ ]
yeah i mean at some point you are going
to be trusting yourself
to the safety of others being on a plane
or in a hotel
truly um and at least where i'm going in
[ __ ] new jersey
they got way less covert there than we
got here they seem to have my kid was
like you can't go
and i was like why they've almost got it
cured in jersey
we're knee-deep into it up here man they
got less covered out there
they should be trying to stop me from
coming there and they might
they might true that's why i got to
drive yeah or like they could get up to
the [ __ ] bridge
going into oh sir turn it around silent
bob
yeah california what you doing back
there hey hollywood
oh you come back now join the quarantine
[ __ ] you hollywood get out of here
that's jersey you can stay in eerie for
all i give a [ __ ]
silent bob all silent up till now now
he's like oh i want to come to jersey
[ __ ] you
go back to being non-talky virginia will
take you
lovers go to virginia um thank you for
hanging out with us here ladies and
gentlemen we'll see you
next week man uh when we come together
to talk about all the stuff that makes
us who we are the stuff that we love
until then
uh for fat man on beyond
for fat man on the beyond that's the new
title fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next time same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith wakanda forever
you